One day the universe will die,
but why and how?
And will the universe be dead forever and how do we know that?
First of all,
the universe is expanding and not only that,
the rate of its expansion is accelerating.
The reason dark energy,
dark energy is a strange phenomenon that scientists believe permeates the
universe.
Until 1998 we thought that the universe must work a bit like a book that you
throw into the sky.
The ball moves up,
but at some point it has to come down again.
But to the expansion of the universe is actually speeding up.
That's length.
Throwing a ball up and watching it fly away faster and faster and faster.
Where is this acceleration coming from?
Well,
we don't know,
but we call it dark energy.
Einstein thought of it first and then decided it was stupid.
Now astrophysicists have decided it is plausible.
Trouble is,
this is all very theoretical and we don't actually know what the properties of
dark energy are,
but there are various theories and they lead us to three scenarios for the end
of the universe.
One,
the big rip.
Since its birth,
the universe has been expanding for unknown reasons.
New Space is created everywhere.
Equally,
the space between got access expands so they move apart.
The space inside galaxies also expands,
but here gravity is strong enough to keep them together.
In the big rip scenario,
the expansion accelerates up to a point West base expansive so fast that gravity
can't compensate for this effect anymore.
The result is a banker rep at first only large structures like galaxies are torn
apart.
Since space between the single objects expands very fast.
Magged big bodies like black holes of stars and planets die there.
Gravity isn't strong enough to keep them together,
so they dissolve into that components in the end space,
but expand faster than the speed of light.
Atoms would now be effected and they would just disband.
One space is expanding faster than light.
No particle in the universe can interact with any other particle anymore.
The universe would dissolve into countless lowly particles that won't be able to
touch anything else in a strange,
timeless universal.
Hmm.
And you thought you felt lonely
to heat death or a big freeze.
In a nutshell,
the difference between the big rip and heat death is that in a heat death
scenario matter stays in tax and is converted over an incredibly long but finite
period of time into radiation while the universe expands forever.
But how does this work?
Let's talk about entropy.
Every system towards the state of highest entropy,
like when we have a Latte Macchiato,
initially it has different regions,
but over time they will cool down and disintegrate until it's uniform.
And this also applies to the universe.
So while the universe gets bigger and bigger matters slowly did and spreads out
at some point after lots of generations of stars,
all the gas clouds necessary to form stars will be exhausted so the universe
will turn dark,
the remaining sons will die,
black holes,
we'll slowly to generate and evaporate over trillions of years due to what's
known as hawking radiation.
When this process is complete,
only a doughnut gas of photons and link particles remains until even this to
case all activity that universal ceases.
At this point,
entropy is at its maximum and the universe is dead forever.
Unless theoretically it might be possible that arts are an incredibly long
amount of time.
There might be a spontaneous entropy decreased as a result of something called
quantum tunneling leading to a new big bang
three big crunch and big bounce.
This is the most uplifting scenario.
If there is less dark and as you than we think or it decreases over time,
gravity will be the dominating force in the universe.
One day.
In a few trillion years,
the rate of expansion of the universe will slow down and stop.
After that,
it reverses.
Galaxies will race it each other merging.
As the universe becomes smaller and smaller.
Since a smaller universe also means our hotter universal temperatures rise
everywhere,
all at once.
100,000 years before the big crunch background radiation would be hotter than
the surfaces of most stars,
which means that they would be cooked from the outside minutes before the big
trunch happens.
Adam cause a ripped apart before supermassive.
Black holes devour everything.
Finally,
all black holes would merge into a super massive mega black hole that contains
the entire massive,
the university.
And in the last moment before the big crunch,
it would devour the universe,
including itself.
The big bounce theory states that this has happened a lot of times under the
universe,
goes through an infinite cycle of expansion and contraction.
Well,
wouldn't that be nice?
So what will actually happen to the universe in the end?
At the moment,
heat death seems the most likely,
but we cuts because I would hope that this dead forever stuff is wrong and the
universe will start over and over again.
We don't know for sure either way.
So let's just assume the most uplifting theory is true,
by the way.
We have a Twitter account.
Okay.